trigger okay so we are live i am talking
with mark drager he is the founder of
phantom media and we are talking today
about
his one word so i believe that every
entrepreneur should find the one word
that defines who they are and bring that
to their business and it's something i
preach i do it on stage you do with my
videos and uh
mark has been a member of my mastermind
group for i don't know how many years
and he actually came to me before i went
on my whole one word crusade and told me
that uh
he was trying to live extraordinary life
and that was his word and so i said mark
you got to tell me
how you found your word
and and we should make this a google
plus hangout so
mark is in where are you mark are you in
florida right now i am i am in florida
it's a it's actually the first rainy day
in about two weeks normally 85 and sunny
all right well it's pretty rainy here in
toronto too so it's raining everywhere
um okay so before we dive in why don't
we just tell everybody about what you do
phantom media so they kind of have a
basis point sure i mean essentially
we're a video production firm uh that
helps businesses market and communicate
and train through video so uh quite
simply i started the company out as a
single person i did everything i did the
shooting i did the selling i did the
editing i did delivery uh and over the
last uh seven and a half years we've
been able to grow to a 10 person team
very cool and so extraordinary
extraordinary is mark mark drager's word
how did you come up with it
well it's funny though because so so
maybe it's a bit different because
because as you mentioned we kind of
reverse engineered this word to a
certain degree so i found for many years
i was doing everything myself and i had
a certain point in the business about
three maybe three and a half years ago
where i was no longer doing the day to
day
and i had hired people to take care of
more more of the billables and the tasks
and and so i used to get my kicks off of
getting stuff completed because if i got
it completed meant that i was generating
money and then i found myself at a point
in the business where i wasn't doing um
billable tasks anymore i had other
people doing it
and and and i it was an achievement but
at the same time i felt a little bit
lost you know i felt like i wasn't
contributing as much as i had or i felt
like like maybe i was actually draining
uh revenue and profit out of the
business because i wasn't doing billable
hours and so i spent like six months i
don't recall but i spent six months kind
of really confused as to what my place
in the business was and finally i got so
frustrated
of feeling like i wasn't contributing
like i didn't have any control anymore
and i thought you know what is this and
you and i happen to be partnered that
month which is which is actually rare
because you don't normally you don't
normally partner up with us
but i remember
thinking
that i
i just
what i was doing in terms of so i'm a
father i'm a christian i'm a husband i'm
a business owner i didn't want to be
ordinary and that's really what it was i
didn't want someone to look at me and
it's it's selfish it's ego i know it's
all of those things but i didn't want
someone to look at me and go
you know there's an ordinary guy i
wanted to be extraordinary or
extraordinary and i remember i remember
kind of confessing this to you on the
phone
and i remember you saying wow that's
really cool and you got a bit of a kick
out of it um
and and then and then we didn't talk
about it for like two and a half or
three years
so
so that's i mean that's ultimately how i
arrived at the word and this was as you
mentioned you know like two or three
years before you really started to lead
this um this this revolution of of
having your one word and it was you who
brought it back to me and said listen
you know two or three years ago you
confessed to me you want to be
extraordinary and and to a certain
degree i think i i was living that but i
wasn't uh i wasn't sharing that with
anyone it was my private thing to myself
i don't even think i mentioned it to my
wife
and um and then in september uh last
year so 2013 you came to me and and
since then it's been like a whirlwind
and it's been so positive and uh as much
as i like to fight you i've i've totally
given in
so the bit so okay that's that's cool
that's some good context did it start
then from the business because you felt
that you were too ordinary in your
business it didn't start from the
personal side it came from in your
business
so i recognized you know i recognized a
really long time ago i don't know how
but i think i in speaking to people but
early on i recognize that my that
everyone has a motivation
and my motivation is recognition
and it comes a bit from my childhood and
it comes from my my past circumstances
but but i am not really motivated by
money i like you know money is great
because it allows you to do certain
things that give you recognition but
really when someone recognizes me for
for being outstanding or being an
achiever or what have you that's that's
my drive
and so the fear so being ordinary the
fear of that is actually just the flip
side of it it's me not living my purpose
it's me not being motivated uh and and
you know i i'm in my early 30s now at
the time i was in my late 20s and i
really thought you know i really worried
that that that i would go into my 30s
and i would arrive at 40 or 45 or 50 and
look back and go i had all this
potential and i didn't tap into it so so
that's really where it comes from it's
just this it's just this impossibly
selfish desire to
to be recognized right so when we spoke
about it you said i wanted to be
extraordinary you had it more mapped out
right i want to extraordinary in my
business
i want to be an extraordinary father i'm
an extraordinary husband
in my faith i want to be extraordinary
so you you took that
and applied it across your life not just
to the business side
but so you seen it started with the
business and then you expanded it to
everything else or was it i mean at once
what got me thinking about it what gets
me thinking about most of the things in
terms of comfort zone in terms of growth
that's that's not my home life i'm i
have i probably have more work to do on
my home life to be a better husband to
be a better father to be more patient to
be a better christian but but it's my
business that makes me think about it
and so the business and me being a
business owner and me feeling a bit lost
not doing daily tasks and billables got
me thinking about it
and and i think i've been able to apply
to the business easier i think it will
always be harder for me to apply to my
personal life
because
because my business is is not only it's
like my hobby it's my passion it's it's
it's it's a lot of things to me and so
uh i got a lot more work to do
being an extraordinary husband being
more patient being a better father
uh unfortunately i got work to do there
well you're never done extraordinary is
an ongoing thing
and it's a high it's a high standard
that's the other thing you know it's
like let's go i didn't know the full
story so it's good um we actually have a
question so one of the people watching
chefs tv wrote in to say hey i believe i
found my one word but i think it'll
sound very cocky if someone were to ask
what advice do you have
well what's the one word
that's
you know
you know any time you put yourself you
you know better than anyone else i've
been probably right you put yourself out
there you've done a lot in the last year
as well and and i'm i'm fortunate
because we get to spend time together
but
but no matter what your word is if it
comes from within you you're you're
you're putting yourself out there for
criticism and so my word to be
extraordinary i know it comes uh and i
try to balance it it comes from from me
wanting to be recognized
uh but but if i'm able to live an
extraordinary life if i'm able to do
extraordinary things then there's almost
a gift in that right and and so i don't
want to be too preachy but if i'm able
to be a much better father then that's a
gift i'm giving my kids and if i'm able
to run an extraordinary business with
extraordinary people then that's a
culture that i'm able to give my staff
and and
and what can we do with that we can be
you know we can take care of other
people we can be more charitable there's
like a lot of benefits that come from it
so if you have an inner word that seems
too cocky
look at the other side of what you can
do with with just living that that that
life
so yeah i i i mean i from my point of
view believe when i first came up with
believe i thought it was too big a word
i thought ah this doesn't work i gotta i
tried to rework and i tried to add more
like believe in yourself believe it
could be done and then the more i looked
to believe it just it felt right and i
just started sharing it so uh
yeah chefs we all want to know what your
one word is so share it if you're still
there i want to put another question in
with your one word so everybody
everybody could know um
no that's great so so so you have
extraordinary you know that came a
couple years ago
you said in
september maybe from my talking to you
you're you know you started
ramping it up now how have you applied
extraordinary to your business and to
your life
so
so we we had we had ingrained this into
our culture already and you and i had a
cup of coffee about it because i was
really challenged when you when you
brought it to me you know you really
challenged me to say you should you
should really start
putting this out there and living it and
so so i had to really look at myself to
say well what parts of my life was i was
i actually living this well do i believe
in it what parts am i actually living
and what parts do i need work on and
ultimately within the culture of our
business we we all were more or less
operating that way but but we could
always do it better it's never going to
end
we weren't sharing the story with anyone
you know we weren't we weren't we were
going through a rebranding process at
the time we're launching a new website
and it wasn't really anywhere on our
website so so the first thing i wanted
to do was from a sales and marketing
point of view
not not um
you know it's not marketing bs it's not
it's it's just how do we in how do we
connect it how do we infuse it in there
so that way what we're putting out there
what we're saying what we're talking
about is in fact how i want the business
to to live and breathe um and then the
next step was let's look at let's look
at the sales process then let's look at
the delivery process and then let's look
at internal operations how work how
we're speaking to one another are
you know is is everything inside the
company extraordinary or is it really
really messy and and ultimately we're
about halfway through probably a
12-month cycle of where we've where
we've really looked outside
we've started looking inside
and and we've had we've completely we're
almost kind of restructuring our
organization actually to make sure that
our clients are finding things
extraordinary so it's not just the work
it's the actual client experience it's
speaking with us it's working with us
internally you know we want everyone i
just i want people to wake up on on a
monday morning go yay i get to go to
work that's to me what being
extraordinary is about um and so it has
to has to kind of go everywhere uh and
it's a really big thing and it can't be
done too quickly
but you know little by little you can
make progress
so what are some of the
as you're trying to implement this and
it's still going to take another x
number of months what are some of the i
guess wins you've had or some of the
hurdles you've had along the way trying
to figure that
out so
i
in terms of wins
you know i i um i worry a lot about what
people think of us and maybe maybe other
people do too i don't know i worry a lot
about what people think of us so the
first being comfortable with it being
extraordinary is to say that not
everyone wants extraordinary i know they
don't
and if you don't that's fine
and i used to worry about wanting to
work with everyone and now i don't want
to work with everyone because if if
for us being extraordinary if you're
going to do it do it the right way or
don't do it at all
uh and if people want to kind of go
halfway then they're not for us so so
the first comfort is saying you know
what when people don't move forward with
working with us it's not really a big
deal
as long as we put out there that we want
to be extraordinary that we want to make
them extraordinary it's their choice
whether they want to move forward or not
so there's comfort in knowing in knowing
that from a sales point of view um
from
i've kind of lost track of the question
i'm sorry
so
so you're trying to implement this right
in your business and in your life we're
talking about you know wins that you've
had and and struggles that you face
along the way to try to make this thing
happen
yeah so so okay thanks so uh internally
i had a bunch of light bulb moments like
leveraging this you know if i want to be
extraordinary extraordinary team and
they need to operate extraordinary and
all of these things since and so i had a
bunch of moments where i was like oh my
goodness is crystal clear to me
that we're not doing this
and so and once once you can identify
the issue you can address it uh and so
within our process and i want to get too
detailed in from a process point of view
within our process we weren't handing
our clients over from one division to
another division as well as we could
and it became really crystal clear that
there was that we were running into kind
of um the clients were fearing this
transition because they just didn't know
it so we do a better job now of setting
that up every step along the way within
our team they uh we had a bunch of
issues operationally and and working
with you and the rest of the mastermind
group i came up with kind of five things
that we need to work on better
uh and and i kind of not to be too
corporate but us we call it the you know
the extraordinary client experience
model and it's because if we want
clients to have an extraordinary
experience not just we're not just
delivering extraordinary work we want
them to actually find the experience of
it extraordinary i mean it meant that
there were five things we had to work on
better
and uh and i rolled that out with the
team and and and i was really really
surprised at that that they found
these tools um they didn't find it uh
suppressing they found it liberating
like i was i was empowering them to now
hold each other accountable and again
none you know maybe i would have tripped
across this but if i hadn't really
started thinking through the lens of of
this one simple word
i don't think i would have gotten there
very cool i like it i like it now how
are you how do you apply it to your life
and the father and husband and your
faith
what what's next for mark drager
well make sure your wife watches this
too
she can hold me accountable what you
commit to you give me my yeah she can be
my uh accountability partner for this
uh
you know it's it
so there's so there's a few things one
i'm actually and this might be
counter-intuitive i'm trying to work
really hard not to compare myself to
other people
and
i'm never going to have what other
people have and they're not going to
have what i have and so it's a few
things it's recognizing what it's being
thankful in recognizing what parts of my
life are extraordinary that i probably
never would have even
taken into account so you know my wife
and i we've been married nine years i
have four kids
um every day
while it's well it's really uh i i lack
patience so to speak
you know i i work to look at my family
life and and uh
so so this is a weird story but i'll
keep it short eight years ago so we
eight years ago we were we were here in
florida where we were and we met a
couple and they were just getting
married and we just happened to run into
the exact same couple now eight years
later
and so eight years ago my wife and i had
just gotten married we had no kids i
hadn't started the business yet we
didn't own our home
and we were really really financially
not doing too well
and so i meet this couple again and and
i thought geez the last time
we spoke to you none of my kids were
alive we didn't have any of these things
we weren't stable and now look at what
we've done in eight years
and to me that's extraordinary so so i
don't want to necessarily compare myself
to other people i just want to look at
what i have and say wow i'm
extraordinary and then i want to look at
how i can do better so how can i be more
patient with my kids how can i provide
for them in areas that i wasn't able to
be provided for when i was younger how
can um how can i raise them up to um to
value um working hard and and ethics and
all these things so
i don't know it's a really really lofty
goal it's being extraordinary is a
really high standard and uh and and
there's a lot of pressure there too so
also
i don't know you got to learn to back
off yes
so chefs wrote back he that his word is
revolutionary oh i love it
i like it too i like it they've you got
to go with big words that's perfect so
so what do you ever what do you think's
cocky about the word revolutionary
you know what i think people have doubt
did you have doubt when you came with
extraordinary when you first thought of
extraordinary did you
did you
was did it just hit you and you're like
wow extraordinary or did you have to
think about it and you doubted it or
what was your process there
it was it was just the word i mean i'm a
marketer so i love wordplay right it was
extraordinary i don't want to be
ordinary i want to be i want to be
extraordinary i want to be extraordinary
and it really clicked and it worked for
me but that's just as i mean that's just
as cocky as as
revolutionary
right or belief like who's to say that
you know who's to say that you're gonna
lead the charge on belief
and so you gotta you gotta so if it
clicks with you it's not gonna click
with everyone right if it clicks with
you i i like that word it's a strong
word word it's a bold word it's gonna
mean that you're outside of your comfort
zone and you're living up to a higher
standard and the people who think that
you're being too arrogant or being too
cocky
they're not they're not gonna get it
right i mean you and i go back and forth
because a lot of times i don't i don't i
don't get everything you're doing but i
but i i get
that you believe in people and you want
others to believe in other people too
that's true well said man you're on the
you're on the believe train right there
i love it yeah there you go
um
how about sharing it so you you you uh
you had this word you used it as kind of
a personal
mission i guess for a little bit and
then
you know i brought it up
a couple years later and
i didn't see it because you weren't
sharing it but you felt you were still
kind of living it so how do you how did
you go from
just doing it yourself to then sharing
it and helping
people see you know and them try to live
extraordinary lives too
well i mean that's that's interesting
because
so where where where i could see where
belief is believe is for others
um
extraordinary is for me so i mean i want
to surround myself with extraordinary
people i want to have extraordinary
experiences
uh
you know i was speaking to someone who
took a year to move to paris so his kids
could learn french and i thought why not
me you know like why can't i do that i
can do that i just need so many years
and i got to do this and do that and to
me that's being extraordinary but i'm
not necessarily sure maybe i'm being
selfish i'm not so sure i want to
empower others to be external i'd love
to
um and that's part of the business
culture i spoke to earlier i'd love to
be able to give that gift but each
person has their own word
and
um
oh geez i lost track of the question
again
i was just talking about sharing it
right because i felt like uh yeah
challenging you right and saying hey
mark is this extraordinary or not yeah
and i'm a cynical marketer and so i want
to make sure that that i'm not um
i don't want to just roll it out i don't
want it to be a campaign
and so um and so i i i'm very i'm still
very guarded about it uh you know we've
we've worked it in in areas uh you know
what it is i want to demonstrate it more
than i want it to be up on posters and
so the word itself we worked in where it
makes sense but equally i use the word
awesome or i use the word amazing
because to me it represents the same
thing and i don't want people to get the
the perception that i've just picked a
word and i want to just kind of poster
it everywhere
and so and so from a rollout point of
view yeah we've worked it in where it
makes sense because it is a bold claim
uh and
uh when we when we share things from
inside our office or our culture we want
it to represent that
and the work we do we want to represent
that and how we go about the work we do
we want to represent that and who we
hire has to fit into that
but i'm not just gonna i'm not just
gonna plaster the word everywhere i want
it to be more the feeling someone gets
from it
uh and that's how i've chosen to roll it
out but at the same time it's because
it's been very slow because
i got to really figure out well what
what does that mean to me in terms of
content and then what does that mean to
other people as well and how are they
going to perceive it
last question uh
advice for somebody who is
watching this and saying wow you know
that it's great to see the impact that
one word has had on mark's life and his
business
i i want to find my one word and figure
that out what advice would you give
somebody who is in that spot doesn't
know what their word is and wants to try
to figure it out
i i think i think you have to
i think more than just the exercise of
finding the word you have to there has
to be like an inner want
right like you got to be i don't know if
you have to be uncomfortable but there
has to be a desire and a kind of a
searching to figure things out so so if
if you have that within you
um i mean i i think the word is very
very very important but that's like the
last step it's more it's more like you
know you have the desire to to figure
things out or to change
and then spend some time figuring out
what that is what what it is that you
want it to look like because i've heard
some other people's words and some of
them really resonate with me and others
others i don't get because it's just not
me and that's fine you know
so you have to do it for you for
yourself not for anyone else and and
maybe sit on it for you know a month or
a few weeks or maybe a few months and
figure out if it feels right before you
share it
but then
so once once you want to change and you
and you kind of plan it out and you find
the word then you got to share it
because i um again from your point of
view we see each other pretty regularly
and you didn't even know that i felt
that i was living my word
uh and i think that's really where i
felt fell down it's not so much for my
story
because i figured out a few years ago
it's not so much that it was really even
hard for me to figure out um because i
wanted to it was that i just never
shared it with anyone and that's that's
what i would do again if i could
very cool
well then watch your video because you
explain it all in in your video find
your word
hey book coming soon too come on man
don't forget the book
all right um
mark thank you
you're on vacation you take the time to
join in this is fantastic our first
google plus hangout i love it um and i
learned too you know i didn't know the
story so that's cool thank you for
sharing um for everybody watching mark
draker phantom media
p-h-a-n-t-a there you go
dia.com video production company based
here in toronto awesome company to check
out
uh we'll keep this live you guys have
any comments questions leave it below
we'll check it out after this thing goes
up on youtube thank you everybody for
watching thank you mark for joining in
chef says thank you mark for answering
my question too
thank yous everywhere
see you guys see you soon
take care